hey everyone good to see you I'm Rena
9in and we're in the CBS this morning
Toyota green room with CNET senior
producer Dan Patterson who is my guru
for all things in tech the ultimate tech
insider I find and we're gonna talk a
little bit about the digital currency
Bitcoin and the technology behind it
called blockchain which kind of blows
people's mind it's hard to understand so
can you just give us sort of the basic
spiel on what exactly is blockchain hey
good morning Rena so that is the age-old
question what is blockchain so if you
think about your do you remember
checkbooks or when you log into your
bank website or load an app on your
phone you see a ledger of every
transaction and the word ledger is kind
of key you'll hear jargon saying a
blockchain is a distributed ledger that
doesn't really explain things but what
it means is that every transaction that
happens with the cryptocurrency Bitcoin
or other crypto currencies is logged for
the public to see and access and you
might say okay so what well every
transaction being logged means that they
are encrypted with this very special
technology the technology that enables
blockchain really is new it is novel and
there are ways that we can take all of
the transactions so instead of thinking
about your bank account think about all
of the bank accounts that exist there
are probably millions or hundreds of
millions of transactions that happen
every day so with the blockchain each
one of these blocks of transactions is
released every five or ten minutes to
the public and what this means is that
the metadata the time date and the
different types of activity are also
logged now the fact that this is
encrypted means that it can't be altered
it can't be changed and that you can
imprint certain things on there again
this all sounds like jargon but what
that really means is that stuff like
your medical transactions or different
types of things that we might want
private but we also want other entities
like a healthcare
provider to own or to interact with can
be we can exchange those things right so
I can own and control my healthcare
records but I can allow my HMO or my
doctor to interact with that record I
love how you compare a Bitcoin to kind
of up to blockchain a kind of looking at
other people's checkbooks I like the
idea of seeing what other people are
doing with their checkbooks but how
exactly is Bitcoin revolutionising other
industries well I don't know that it is
we hear all of this hype right and
that's really the hype to practicality
ratio is like ten to one so there are
industries especially healthcare I love
looking at healthcare because that is
something we can all understand my
healthcare records are my records they
have to do with my health but I might
want someone else to be able to interact
with those things other industries are
really taking to blockchain they like
financial services so we hear about
FinTech that also sounds like jargon but
if you think about something like venmo
right where I can seamlessly very easily
send cash between different people I
don't have to think about what's
happening on the back end I can just
send cash well if we have a consortium
of banks meaning every bank that you or
I may use it's way easier if we have
blockchain technology that enables us to
send or receive large sums of money so I
get that it can send and receive large
sums of money but how do you think it
can change the way regular folks live
and deal with money that is still up for
debate and and I I believe in the
potential technology and the the
potential uses of this technology but
I've yet to see and I've been looking at
the blockchain space for over five years
and I've yet to see something that
really is applicable for normal everyday
people and that's something to keep in
mind now there's a difference between
blockchain tech and cryptocurrency
crypto currency like Bitcoin or you'll
hear of aetherium or ripple all of these
are different incentive mechanisms so
the blockchain works by pointing a lot
of processing power at particular code
the code
the blockchain code is it requires that
we solve these very complex math
problems so the more processing power
that you throw at these the better you
are at solving these problems that will
then release a Bitcoin or in a theory a
piece of ether right these different
chains have different names so ripple
will will release a different type of
currency that incentivizes people to
make the chain stronger by mining it by
pointing you're very powerful processor
at that you know it's like this black
hole when we talk about cryptocurrency
it's kind of hard to wrap your head
around it do you find that
cryptocurrency is practical or is this
just sort of a speculative market it's
very speculative right now the practical
uses for cryptocurrency right now the
way it is bought and sold and spent is
primarily on the dark web the dark web
is the encrypted Internet you need a
special browser called tor to visit the
dark web and the services that you can
use cryptocurrency for are primarily
illegal activities so when we talk about
things that are very practical all of
that kind of stays in the realm of the
abstract and the hypothetical the one
way that I see cryptocurrency being used
right now and it kind of gives me some
anxiety is if we look at Venezuela the
economy is tanking and people are
dumping their cash money into crypto
currencies this may be more of a symptom
of a bad economy than it is an indicator
the crypto currency is the real deal you
know one of the key words that comes up
when you're trying to understand
blockchain is decentralization of data
what does that mean so decentralization
of data it's almost impossible to talk
about the blockchain without using
jargon so what this means is instead of
a bank controlling your currency your
money it is locked to the blockchain so
you can have proof that this coin is
authentic and it's a part of the chain
right so instead of having a bank say
yes your dollars or your credits in your
account are real you have a
decentralized Authority now this becomes
very powerful again when we look at
medical records right
instead of having one organization take
care of the ownership of my medical
records and this can be problematic
especially when we look at all these
hacks and you know data leaks Equifax
last year a lot of personal information
was leaked to the public having the
stored in an encrypted way in the
blockchain makes a lot of sense because
it's decentralized but we've heard this
language before I'm a big believer in
open source and decentralization but we
look at you know just ten years ago what
happened with RSS and OPM now these
again are coding languages that promised
a decentralized Internet and yet
everything becomes closed so anytime we
talk about decentralization especially
with the blockchain we can look at
what's already happening there's Bitcoin
but there's also ripple etherium all of
these other chains that are closed and
private you know Tim berners-lee the man
who invented the internet he says that
blockchain could actually really help
and pushing back against tech giants
like Google and might restore Internet
to the way he initially envisioned it
can you sort of explain the thinking
behind that and do you buy that I don't
know that I buy it i buy the vision and
i understand why tim berners-lee would
say this and i think many people who
were in the tech space kind of have this
vision of a web that is open and free
and that is not the reality that we've
ever encountered so the internet used to
be you know we use HTTP right and when
you put that into your browser that
stands for hypertext Transfer Protocol
and all of this are open ways open
source meaning no one company owns this
way of communicating and HTTP is a way
of telling a web browser hey go to this
IP address and load this website that's
great email also an open protocol you
don't need Gmail you don't need
Microsoft Outlook those are private ways
of doing an email protocol SMTP I
understand why Tim berners-lee wants
this and we see a history of the web
where innovators
look at open source and they say hey
let's make all of these protocols that
can interoperate with each other and
then we see the Facebook's of the world
the googles of the world the Twitter's
of the world say hey great idea let's
privatize it and make some money on them
you know this week we know that Facebook
came forward and talked about a
disinformation campaign dealing with
potentially the midterms do you think
blockchain could have made a difference
with that yes and no so everything again
with blockchain is hypothetical one of
the great hypothetical uses of
blockchain is the media industry so we
saw in 2016
not just meddling with BOTS and other
things that kind of propped up some
candidates we also saw the spread of
what we call now fake news now we can't
prevent anyone from setting up a fake
website and disseminating fake
information but right now a massive
trend that we see Google Twitter and
Facebook engaging in is verifying
information and verification is the key
to the blockchain again because the the
way the code is written you can verify
that a piece of not just currency piece
of Bitcoin but other information you can
verify that this is authentic and real
so if we take a photo here at CBS News
or the New York Times or anywhere else
or we write a story we could imprint
that on a news chain a fork of the
blockchain or any other type of
blockchain technology and then be able
to say this is authentic it is the date
stamp the the date and time stamp is
real the author's byline is real so at
the very least you can say well this is
major media that has been reported and
verified accurate but that also kind of
prevents legitimate bloggers or smaller
pieces of independent media from rising
to the top and so you end up with a
segregated internet this is again a
theoretical use segregated internet
fascinating to hear you talk about
blockchain and the many uses Dan
Patterson I want to thank you so much
for joining us I think all of you out
there on Facebook for joining us as well
thank you